hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show where in this video we're going to
talk about
the protein folding problem and how
alpha folds a program developed by deep
minds
may have finally solved and perhaps we
could call it
alpha gold considering how well it
outperformed all of the other
competitors
at the recent casper fence standing for
critical assessment of protein structure
prediction
which is an event that happens every two
years beginning back in 1994 whereby
each computing team is given 100
different
protein sequences and are given the task
of being able to predict the protein
structure for that protein sequence
their predictions are then compared to
the experimental model that
has already been collected but not yet
released to the public
now being able to predict a protein
structure from its amino acid sequence
is not a trivial task in fact it's been
a grand challenge for more than 50 years
and this is because there are so many
potential applications of having the
ability to predict a protein structure
and we'll allude to some of these at the
end of the video and it's also why it's
so impressive
to see these results from deepmind that
they can actually now predict a protein
structure just by its amino acid
sequence that
in some cases almost matches an actual
experimental model
of the protein structure so hopefully by
the end of this video you will
understand why
alpha folds will change everything and
so to do this we'll start by looking at
what is the protein folding problem
and give you an introduction to protein
sequences
and protein folding and then we'll look
at alpha folds
and the way that they make these
predictions and discuss whether
structural biologists
so scientists who actually get the
experimental structures or proteins
using a variety of different techniques
such as x-rays nmr
and cryo-em and discuss whether or not
they're out of a job
and also talk about the next steps for
our fold
and where next improvements need to be
made and then lastly as i said we'll
look at the uses and applications
of alpha fold and why this is such a
great achievement
so first then what is the protein
folding problem
well when i normally talk about proteins
on this channel i typically just draw a
circle and write the protein's name and
sides
however proteins don't look like that
proteins come in all different shapes
and sizes
and it can be said that the final
structure of a protein can determine
what that protein's function is
for example my favorite protein p53 has
a region that enables it to bind dna
it has a dna binding domain and so if
another protein also had the same
dna binding domain i would also go maybe
it's going to bind to dna
but that's the final structure of a
protein all proteins are composed of a
series of building blocks referred to as
amino acids there are 20 different amino
acids and the sequence of those amino
acids
dictates the final structure of a
protein so the protein folding problem
seeks to understand how the sequence of
amino acids
enables the production of the 3d
structure
of a protein so the protein folding
problem is under the assumption
that all the information for folding the
individual amino acids
otherwise referred to as the residues is
actually in
the amino acid sequence and this
assumption was proved experimentally
by christian athenson in a very nice
series of experiments where he nicely
demonstrates that all the information
for folding residues is in the amino
acid sequence
and this is well summarized in this
figure here so the protein that he was
looking at
is called ribonuclease and to form the
final 3d structure of ribonuclease
there are four bonds that are really
important and
as i failed to mention earlier it's the
formation of a variety of different
bonds
between these different amino acids that
actually enables these 3d structures of
proteins to form
so what he did with this ribonuclease is
that he added chemicals
in this case urea and mercaptoethanol
that caused these bonds to break
which you can see here and this caused
the structure of the protein to unravel
by then removing this urea and
re-oxidizing the solution
the protein structure was able to reform
as the conditions now enabled
these disulfide bonds to reform also
allowing the structure to
reform and restoring the activity of the
ribonuclease
however if you change the order of a
fence such that you re-oxidize the
solution
before urea is removed then the protein
incorrectly folds however this can be
restored by adding a reducing agent
that then enables the native structure
of the protein to be formed with the
correct bonds forming between
the amino acids and so effectively what
all of this does prove
is that all of the information that we
need is in the amino acid sequence
and so the question then is how hence
the protein farting problem
so what do we know well we know that
there are different forces that are
driving a protein into its 3d folded
structure
and the final structure often referred
to as the native structure
has the lowest free energy and so one
way of kind of
envisioning how this process works this
folding process
is the protein folding funnel whereby
you can see there's different routes of
folding that result in the final
protein structure and also suggests that
the order in which the protein starts to
fold is also important
for achieving the native states so what
are these different forces that drive a
protein to fold
well there are a variety of different
forces that come into play
but one thing i want to mention is the
importance of the type of amino acid
that's present in the sequence
different amino acids have different
so-called r-groups
that contain different atoms and this
gives the amino acids individual
different properties so some amino acids
have a positive charge
whilst others have a negative charge and
some have no charge at all
well that's never really quite true and
so as an example
an amino acid with a positive charge may
be forming
interactions with another amino acid
with a negative charge but these two
amino acids
don't have to be adjacent in the amino
acid sequence
they could be much farther apart but due
to the 3d confirmation of the final
protein
they could be now in close proximity
another thing that is worth mentioning
is that we understand
protein folding by using the different
levels of protein organization
so starting with the amino acid sequence
that is often referred to as the primary
structure and this final structure here
of the 3d folded protein
is referred to as the tertiary structure
and so
in between the primary structure the
sequence and the tertiary structure the
final
3d structure of the protein are you
guessed it
secondary structures the two main
secondary structures
are beta strands and alpha helices and
it's understood that the series of
different strands and helices within the
secondary structure
make up the tertiary structure so
actually if we take a closer look at
this tertiary structure here
we can actually see that it's made up of
these different helices these alpha
helices
and these different beta strands the the
ones that look like arrows
and it turns out that different amino
acids have different propensities
of forming either beta strands or alpha
helices
and so already we've got some
information about the amino acid
sequence and what the secondary
structure could be
but looking at different amino acids
propensities of forming beta sheets or
alpha helices
is nowhere near sufficient to be able to
create a 3d final structure of a protein
we need a lot more information and one
really valuable bit of information
comes from the use of evolutionary
covariation data
now that may sound complicated but we'll
get to it
basically this approach uses the power
of comparing
the protein sequence to the same protein
sequence found in different organisms
for example mice rats snakes
dogs cats whales you get my point
and you take the same sequences from
these different organisms and you form
multiple sequence alignments you see
which amino acids are the same or
different
in the different species now this is
really important for identifying amino
acids that are really important in the
folding process
and so if we go back to that example i
mentioned earlier about having
a positively charged amino acid and a
negatively charged one
that are forming an interaction in 3d
space that's important for the final
structure of a protein
i can generate a hypothetical example to
try and explain to you the importance of
this evolutionary covariation data
so in this example sequence
let's say we've got nine amino acids
here
and one of them is this positively
charged amino acids
so it could be lysine and one of them is
negatively charged
so it could be glutamate and let's just
assume for simplicity that the rest of
the amino acids are glycine
okay so we've got this positively
charged amino acid and we got this
negatively charged one
now let's compare this sequence to these
different species
so we can see in this case that the dog
also has the same
positive and negative charged amino acid
it's got that lysine and glutamate
and it's also present in the whale but
if we look at the cats
the cat actually has them switched
around it's got the negatively charged
amino acid first
and the positively charged one seconds
and what you might notice as well
is that we don't seem to have any
species that have two positive
amino acids and either those positions
or two negative amino acids in either of
those positions
suggesting that those two residues show
evolutionary co-variation
if one of them changes the other one has
to change to maintain
an interaction between those two
positions in the final 3d structure
and so i've only really talked about two
different
features that can be extracted from the
protein sequence
that give us a better understanding of
what the final 3d structure might look
like
but there's a lot more features that
could be analyzed i mean i could be
talking about it all day
but i don't think you really want that
right now but the challenge
is taking all this information and being
able to put it all together
and try and work out what the final
structure is
and so this is when machine learning
techniques come into play
and so this is when we can now come back
to the casp competition
whereby different companies different
labs have generated
different programs using different
techniques to extract the information
from a protein sequence
and try and predict accurate 3d protein
models
and given that this year was casper 13
it's not a trivial process however
as i said at the start of this video
alpha folds
has got very close at least in some
cases
as you can see in this figure here to
actually
getting very accurate prediction of a 3d
structure such that it almost
virtually overlaps with the actual
collected experimental data
but we'll come back to that as well at
the end so how do they actually do it
well the first concept we have to get in
our heads is to understand
what they mean by a folded protein can
be thought of as a spatial graph
and so effectively if we draw a set of
3d coordinates
and plunk in a protein in the middle
effectively if you wanted to do a kind
of sketch
of what that protein would look like you
would need to have a
three-point coordinate to match where
each amino acid will be positioned
within that
3d graph i don't know if that made any
sense and then based on the order of
amino acids in a sequence you can then
just do a line that kind of connects
all up together so in this kind of dodgy
drawing i've done here i've tried to
demonstrate that i've
pinpointed an alpha helix and so if i do
my line you can see that you've got
an alpha helix and there's also there's
a beta strands in there as well
the point is is that we can actually
plot a protein structure onto a graph
and then the question is what are the
points of each of the amino acids that's
the information that we need
so two really important bits of
information they can generate
to get those positions is firstly
getting the
pairwise distances between residues so
if i just take this residue for example
is finding out what the distance is
between this residue
and all the different residues within
the protein and secondly
finding out what the angle is between
this amino acid residue
and the one either side of it the
so-called backbone
torsion angles these two bits of
information are vital to being able to
create a 3d structure representation
and so the latest version of alpha fold
which they presented
at casper 14 got it right this time
involves using
neural network system which they call an
attention-based
neural network system that attempts to
interpret the structure of this graph
while reasoning over the implicit graph
that it's building
so effectively what this means is how
they can use all these different
features that they can extract from the
protein sequence
to generate these pairwise distances and
angles to generate their structure
and so this is better shown if we look
at their neural network
model architecture so we can see here
their protein sequence and then we can
see that they perform this multiple
sequence alignment that i mentioned
earlier which basically exploits the
evolutionary
history by comparing two different
species
sequences and comparing that sequence to
that found in different species
to identify important amino acid contact
points
and then also looking at a variety of
other features
that enable you to calculate these
pairwise distances between the residues
and although they haven't actually
published a paper yet talking about
their updated alpha fold system
it seems to be that this process is
iterative such that the information is
passed between these different
these different representations to then
finally generate
a matrix that gives the information to
form the final 3d structure
so how long does this process take well
if we go to a cell
it can fold a protein in a fraction of a
second so
fast and if we go to experimental models
such as
x-ray crystallography or nmr or query m
it can take months up to several years
to get a final 3d structure
deepmind's alpha folds can do it in a
couple of days
and it's not just fast compared to
experimental approaches
but it's also accurate they achieved a
score of 92.4
across all of their targets at casper 14
and so this score effectively takes into
account
how far each amino acid residue in their
predicted model
is from the actual experimental model so
does this mean that
structural biologists who generate
protein structures
using query m x-ray nmr are out of the
job
well not quite firstly alpha fold was
trained by using the publicly available
data
consisting of a of around 170 000
protein structures
that have been experimentally generated
so if they want to improve alpha fold
they need to be able to at least compare
it to some experimental data
and i initially thought that this might
be quite a weak argument
but especially for the validation it's
actually quite important
it's important to know if the structures
that they're predicting are actually
correct
and secondly x-ray crystallography and
chromium
just the two examples have seen massive
improvements over the last few years
and they can actually generate
information that can't be gained by
using alpha folds
for example you can now get chromium
structures of not just one protein but
entire protein complexes how one protein
is sandwiched
amongst other proteins and having a full
pitch of the entire complex
gives you so much more information than
just that protein individually
as many proteins function in a cell as a
complex
a second advantage to experimental
approaches is that you can get
the protein on different structures for
example going back to my favorite
protein p53
a decent number of structures have been
released that not only show p53 in its
tetrameric form
so it doesn't work alone it works with
four of its equal bodies
but it also includes dna in the
structure
so we can see how the protein is
interacting with the dna
and it's not just dna we can do it with
rna or other small molecules
using experimental systems and so far
alpha folds i don't think it can
actually do any of that
it's just getting the structure of a
protein based on one
individual amino acid sequence and
another advantage to experimental
approaches such as using nmr
nuclear magnetic resonance you can
sometimes get
quite an insight into the dynamics of a
protein
because proteins i mean we draw them as
like static entities
but in a cell that all you know did all
sorts of kind of
conformational changes and that's also
really important for a protein function
but yes there are many advantages to
alpha folds
not only the speed as i mentioned
earlier it's kind of crazy how fast it
is in comparison to
some of the x-ray structures but it's
also useful for
being able to generate at least
predicted
structures for proteins that previously
were really challenging
to try and crystallize because i mean
the reason x-ray crystallography
aquarium takes so long is because it's
so hard to get the right experimental
conditions
in which a protein may actually
crystallize and you may never find that
condition
some proteins may never crystallize
which is why having something like alpha
folds where it can predict
you know we'll never know how accurate
it is or maybe not as accurate but it's
better than having no structure at all
and so i think this nicely brings me on
to what are the uses of having protein
structures
and i'm actually going to kind of split
this into two firstly
talk about the use of having protein
folding structure
oh man having protein folding predicting
systems the advantages of those and what
we can use with that information
and then we're generally looking at what
we can gain from a protein structure
so let's start with the use of having
something like alpha folds
well what's really interesting about
alpha fold is that
it collects all this different
information about amino acid sequences
and brings it all together to generate a
3d structure
and now one thing that would be really
interesting would be to kind of
reverse this process and work backwards
to try and understand
what information it was using what was
more important to generate
the 3d structure of prediction as that
might give us some information
into how the folding mechanism actually
works within a cell
because that you know understanding the
folding mechanism is one of the
aspects that goes along with trying to
crack the protein folding problem
and if this could be understood it may
also then be possible to
create your own protein structure and
then to use the reverse mechanism to
kind of see what the original protein
sequence would be
but i think i'm a little bit ahead of
myself what are the actual more
practical uses of
alpha folds well firstly having protein
structures gives us insight into the
protein's function
and that's just useful for understanding
what that cell's doing
and understanding what's going on within
each of our cells
and by being more specific there's a
variety of things that we can get with a
protein structure
firstly it gives us an understanding of
interactions for example with different
drugs and so this is really useful for
drug discovery
and therapeutics and then secondly a lot
of diseases are caused by genetic
mutations
within within different genes and those
genetic mutations can often
alter the amino acid present within a
protein and so by having this predictive
system we can see how the protein
changes
when that amino acid is changed and try
to understand
the disease mechanism and similarly with
this
actually kind of a bit not quite related
um
are diseases such as alzheimer's disease
and type 2 diabetes were it's often seen
that proteins
aggregate and understanding the
aggregation process can be greatly aided
by having the structures of these
different proteins
for example the tau protein which is the
protein that that
can aggregate in alzheimer's disease was
only recently solved by chronium
but it's one of those proteins that was
really challenging to study and so
something like alpha folds is a really
great tool
and similarly loss of proteostasis
happens in the aging process
so understanding how protein structures
change during age could also
be aided through alpha folds but my
point is there's a lot of applications
of using something like alpha folds
i mean there wouldn't be the casper
competition to begin with if it wasn't
going to be important
and so hopefully this video has given
you some insights into protein folding
into the alpha fold system and into the
potential applications
and so maybe now we can understand this
quote that it will change
everything which i used as a little bit
of clickbait for this video
i guess i'll see you later if it
actually worked um anyway so
as always i hope we've learned something
in this video um i actually really
enjoyed making this one
i got proper nerdy and into it but i
hope you've learned something
and as always thanks for listening